yesterday on the show we debuted a new
bit it was in response to an insane
situation that our executive producer
Jeff Ross has been going through the
last couple days Jeff this is true right
it's right there right there
quick recap and Jeff you told me if I'm
wrong Jeff went to rent a car from Hertz
this is a completely true story boo
so cats cats and Hertz are out Jeff went
to rent a car from Hertz something he's
done hundreds of times before and after
picking a vehicle on their website this
is what he saw for a day for the
Chevrolet Impala 8799 dot 89 cents okay
clearly a mistake but Jeff was unable to
get anybody it hurts to admit it was a
mistake and changed the price they're
giving him the runaround is this right
Jeff you tried you-you-you wrote them a
letter you called them multiple time you
tweeted them you hope you have a
tweeting account a Twitter account the
first time I ever tweeted yeah okay Wow
I didn't know he hit for that old crank
Twitter
hey anyway having fun over here it's my
show see
so anyway Jeff was not getting any
response from hurt so last night I
decided to step in and attack the
problem with some celebrity power that's
right
I dropped the gloves and I called Hertz
out last night in a new piece I call
Ross wronged Ross wrong dude come on
hurts why you got to play me like that
[Music]
okay well as predicted it was extremely
effective this morning Hertz's senior
director of customer service contacted
Jeff informed him that they've now
changed the day rate for the Impala from
eight thousand seven hundred ninety nine
dollars and eighty nine cents to a
hundred and fourteen dollars and forty
cents
[Applause]
good work Hertz you came through you
came through Hertz and I'm proud of you
but this is just the beginning I'm
issuing a warning to every corporation
out there do not wrong Ross because from
now on
Ross wronged is going to be a regular
segment on our show if any company or
service ever wrongs Jeff Ross or even
mildly inconveniences him the way Hertz
did you'll have to answer the question
that all of America
will be asking come on company or
service why you got to play me like that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he's like he's like Porky Pig on paxil
that's all folks are you gonna play
that's all folks
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography